okay to the war in ukraine now and
ukrainian authorities say their forces
targeted a russian ammunition depot in
the south of the country overnight
resulting in a massive explosion
captured on social media well it comes
as the battle for the east of the
country continues for more on this i'm
joined now by defence and security
expert professor michael clark
let's talk about the latest on the
overall situation in ukraine if we can
first michael yes i mean as in all wars
there's a lot happening but sometimes it
doesn't appear to be moving much on the
ground so there's an operational pause
going on uh in the donbass which is
where our focus is mainly the russians
took severe donetsk and schansk they
were moving towards slaviansk but they
won't get there for a little while
because they're preparing that battle
and the moment the attention is on this
uh the main highway the e40 one of the
great european highways runs from calais
to kazakhstan and the part of it that
runs through ukraine goes from kharkiv
to slavyansk to luhansk and so that that
highway is a very important strategic um
artery that both sides are now competing
over that's that will dominate really
the uh the battle for slavians that will
start quite soon most of the attention
of course is a bit further south west
now where there is some real change i
think okay well let's take our viewers
there then and and look at the city of
clearson uh what's happening there and
of course the surrounding areas yeah
well the um ukrainians began this big
offensive uh three weeks ago now and
they're moving uh to the north west of
kershawn and they're trying to move in
on kershaw city they expect to be able
to produce a strategic
gain there a big strategic gain sometime
soon we'll see if they can it's it's a
tough one but the next couple of weeks i
think will be important meanwhile at
nova kokovka which is the dam it's where
the dam is that feeds the water into
crimea big place um there's a huge
explosion that you mentioned massive
artillery explosion the biggest that
we've seen so far the ukrainians
targeted the ammunition depot at
novakovka which is at the end of a rail
junction on the on one of the bridges
over the nepa river and it was huge and
that particular explosion they say the
ukrainians say was created by their
himars which is their system that's the
explosion nobody's seen one quite this
big before there's lots of it on social
media most uh commentary is that it's
probably grad rockets as well as
artillery ammunition so a huge amount
because it was a very big concentration
of ammunition everyone knew where it was
the russians made their attempt to
disperse it it was all there there to be
hit and the the hitting was done by this
uh mobile multiple launch rocket system
called the himars the high mobility
rocket artillery there it is um the
thing about the himars it's not the
heaviest system at all it's quite light
it's a wheeled vehicle so it's it has to
stay on the roads but that means it's
quick it's fast the cassette carries six
uh missiles and that cassette can be
switched in about three minutes it's a
three-man team on the on the vehicle so
these vehicles can shoot and scoot they
can fire off the six rockets each one is
very accurate and then they can be away
and the russians just can't find them
yeah this is actually the kit we've been
talking about over the last few months
that they really desperately wanted
aren't we so what are the russians now
doing to deal with these hit-and-run
tactics can they counter them they're
looking for them um the the ukrainians
only seem to have about eight which is a
ridiculously small number maybe four
more are on the way but it's a handful
but at the moment they're able to shoot
and scoot and keep out of the way
because the russians have not got
control of what's happening in the air
they don't actually know what what the
ground situation is and uh this morning
american intelligence reported that the
russians are getting a series of they
said hundreds of drones from iran so the
iranians are the drones that the
iranians have given to the houthi rebels
in yemen they're now going to give to
russia president putin announced today
or the kremlin announced this morning
that putin was going to iran next week
so it looks as if the russians are
trying to invest in a lot more drones
because they just don't have an image of
what's happening on the ground unless
they can get that image unless they can
get good intelligence they can't find
these this small handful of himars that
are doing them such damage and until
they do the fact is every night now
every night belongs to the himalas
wow fascinating insights what's going on
thank you professor michael clark